-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm hanging out with
Austin Butler!
He stars in the new "Elvis"
biopic out June 24th.
In honor of that, we're about to
play a new game called
"Biopic-tionary."
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ Bio-bio-bio-pictionary ♪
-Alright. there you go, bud.
Now, it works exactly like
Pictionary, okay?
Except all the clues that
we're guessing are based --
are titles of popular biopics.
Okay? Now, we each have
a stack of cards.
You have one, I have one, okay?
Now, you're going to
pick a card,
then start drawing on
these iPads.
Everything you draw
will be seen on the screen.
-And we show it to each other?
-No.
It's going to be
seen on a screen behind us.
-Oh, wow.
-Right there. Yeah.
Technology. Look at that.
Isn't that amazing?
-Yeah. I'm not that good at
drawing, so let's see.
-That's all right.
Well, once you start drawing,
the other person
has 20 seconds to guess.
-Okay.
-Okay?
And it's the name of a biopic.
-Alright.
-So some -- Yeah.
Some biography thing.
Alright,
so since you're my guest
and it's your first time on
"The Tonight Show,"
you go first.
-I draw first?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm going to
make it hard for you. Yeah.
It's alright. Come on, partner.
We can do it.
-Alright. Okay.
So I look at this first.
-Yeah, you look at that part.
-And I got 20 seconds
to give it to you.
-Yep.
-Alright, hold on.
-Yeah, no problem.
-Okay, here we go.
Oh, geez. Alright.
-Oh, a horn. Bull?
-Yeah.
-Chicago Bulls, Michael Jordan.
The five -- The something.
Game 5 or something.
What is it?
The Five -- Oh, it's a devil.
-No, no, no, no.
-It's not the devil.
No, it's a bull.
Is it -- No, no, no.
Alright, so, hold on.
-Alright, sorry.
-[ Growls ]
-Is that a basketball? No.
[ Buzzer ]
Sorry.
Oh, yeah, I was totally off.
-No, no.
-Wait.
-He's angry.
He's raging.
-"Raging Bull"!
Oh, it's -- Alright.
♪♪
Alright, alright. That's fine.
Alright. Sorry about that.
Okay, so, now you
press that to clear it.
-Oh, we need to clear it?
-Yeah. Sorry.
Alright, didn't get that one.
I was thinking
the Michael Jordan one.
Okay. It's alright.
I still couldn't
think of the name.
-Chicago Bulls.
-Oh, okay.
Ooh! Ooh! Okay.
Alright. Ready?
-Yes.
-Okay.
♪♪
-A box.
Book?
Dollar, dollar.
Money. Money.
Man.
Breasts. What?
Arms holding money.
[ Buzzer ]
-Sorry, not breasts.
Sorry.
That was supposed to be...
Oh, my gosh. Don't ever...
-I'm sorry.
-Sorry, what?
That was
supposed to be a guitar.
Sorry.
-Oh, geez.
A guitar.
-Don't ever let him see this.
Yeah, this is --
Or any of the family.
That is -- That's supposed
to be Johnny Cash.
-That was "Walk the Line"?
-That was "Walk the Line."
Sorry about that.
Wow! How do I clear that --
How do I clear that fast?
Sorry, I --
-But what's with this money?
-That was a guitar
and it was a stack of cash.
-So, he's making money
playing the guitar.
-I figured Johnny Cash,
if you said "cash."
-Oh, "cash"!
-Yeah, we would have got it.
Yeah, but, anyways, it did not
look anything like a guitar.
Okay.
-Alright, so, what are?
1 for...
-We're at 0-0.
-0 for 0. Okay.
-But, yeah, we need get to one.
Here you go. Pick up this card.
We can do it.
Come on, Austin. We got this.
-Hold on one second.
♪♪
Okay, you got this one.
-This is Round 2. Here we go.
-Alright, come on.
-Yep.
House.
-Yes.
-Doorknob's in the middle
of the door. Interesting.
Window.
-No.
-No. It's not a window.
Oh -- "House of Gucci"!
-Yes!
-Wow!
-Yeah.
[ Dinging ]
Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about.
-I knew the bag.
-There we go.
-House and the bag. That's it.
Well done!
-Alright.
-Lady Gaga!
Love it.
-Alright.
-Alright, bud. Here we go.
-Okay, clear it.
-Okay. Now -- Alright.
♪♪
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
We got this. We got this.
We got this.
-Okay.
-Alright, ready?
-We're merging our minds.
-Yes. Here we go.
Alright, here we go.
-Okay.
Oh, I can look at that, too?
Lincoln?
-Yes!
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the best drawing
I ever --
-I wasn't expecting that one.
-That's the best drawing
I ever did.
-That was amazing.
-That was the best drawing
I've ever done.
-That was incredible.
-I've never done
a better drawing in my life.
Compared to the Johnny Cash one,
that's much better.
-That was good.
[ "Jailhouse Rock" plays ]
-Uh-huh-huh.
-Oh, wait a second.
That sound means it's time
for the final round.
[ Laughter ]
What else would that sound mean?
So, this one, you and I
will be drawing together,
and we're going to try to get
Questlove to guess the biopic.
-Oh. Oh! Good luck.
-Quest, are you good
with your biopics?
-I'm good with it.
Can I hear that theme
again, though?
[ "Jailhouse Rock" plays ]
-Uh-huh-huh.
-Alright, good. Now, look.
That's one of our writers.
-We both are
synced to the same thing?
-We're synced to the same thing.
We're both drawing on
the same screen.
We can help each other out.
-Okay.
-And we're gonna get
Quest to guess this.
Are you ready for this?
-Okay.
Oh. Okay.
Alright, you want to
take that part?
-Yeah. Yeah. Okay, yeah.
-Oh, all right.
-Yeah. Alright, ready? Go.
-You gonna draw that...
Oh, oh.
Yeah, yeah. Good job.
-What is that?
Alright, so, then --
-Alright, "Rocketman"?
Elton John.
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
-It's that easy. Come on, man.
It's that easy.
-It's that easy.
-Wow.
-Good man, Quest.
Austin Butler, everybody.
"Elvis" hits theaters June 24th.
Check it out.
We'll be right back with tWitch.
Stick around, everybody.